На годиннику сьома ранку, а робота на городі кипить.
Тридцятидвохрічній Олені разом з іншими працівниками слід прибрати це поле цвітної капусти.
Сюди, в село Великі Копані на Херсонщині, жінка приїхала на заробітки разом з чоловіком.
Хоча спершу планувала їхати до Польщі.
Прокормити сім'ю, дітей, в селі роботи немає. Ось так через знайомих сюди попала.
В планах було виїхати, але зараз - ні.
Зараз мене поки все влаштовує: до дітей ближче і чоловік поруч.
В Олени двоє дітей шкільного віку, ось заради них і працює вже не перший рік на сезонних роботах.
В її рідному селі, що за 140 кілометрів звідси, роботи немає.
Натомість у селі Великі Копані через сприятливий клімат у кожному дворі
вирощують городину на продаж. Тож місцеві селяни і самі працевлаштовані,
і роботу для інших мають.
Сезон у нас закінчується в грудні: в балаганах кабачки, до сильних морозів ми їх тягнемо.
А починаємо рано з дев'ятого січня садимо редиску,
в березні її прибираємо і вже садимо перці.
Далі кабаки, знову редиска. У нас вихідний лише місяць.
Зазвичай Ірина наймає 5-6 осіб. Втім, коли треба швидко прибрати городину,
приміром цибулю, то бере на роботу ще бригаду з двадцяти людей.
За годину роботи платить 40 гривень та дає безкоштовні обіди.
Знайти працівників не важко. За спостереженнями Ірини, щороку людей,
які для заробітків обирають Україну, а не, наприклад, Польщу, стає чимраз більше.
Більше сюди у нас їдуть. Була у нас дівчинка з Новоолександрівки і каже,
що в Польщі набагато важче, а грошей більше заробити можна в Копанях.
Якщо вона не вживає, не курить, у неї вдома діти, то заробила гроші,
сіла і поїхала додому. У неї сестра зараз  їде в Польщу, то, каже, побачить,
що там, яка різниця. Якщо що, то наступного разу теж сюди приїде, а не у Польщу. Бо ж ближче.
Фермерам у Великих Копанях зручно ще й тому, що в селі розташований
найбільший на півдні України гуртовий сільськогосподарський ринок "Нежданний".
Тож тут свою продукцію одразу й продають.
Поряд з фермерами і перекупщиками, свою полуницю рекламує
і подружня пара з Черкащини. Вони теж приїхали на Херсонщину на заробітки.
Людмила 4 роки працювала в Польщі на сезонних роботах.
Каже, найбільша сума, яку вдалося привезти - 14 тисяч гривень.
А тут набагато вигідніше… Я сюди вже 4 рік їжу, я можу менше робити, але більше приводжу.
Ми от з сестрою їздимо,  бригади возимо: одна працює, а інша бригадиром,
то ми вже за три тижні  чистими більше 40 тисяч гривень на двох.
І це чисті, не те що ще треба скупитись, потратити на щось.
Не їдемо в Польщу, бо і в Україні можна заробити ще більше грошей, ніж у Польщі.
Ринок працює цілодобово та без вихідних, тож шум автівок в селі практично не стихає.
Втім, на це тут майже ніхто не нарікає, адже ринок - джерело доходу
ледь не кожного місцевого селянина.
Сільський виробник виростив продукцію, загрузив в машину
і привіз до нас на ринок,  але він хоче продати зразу все, а не по кілограму.
Ось, ця людина виростила редиску і в нього є дві тонни
і він шукає людину, яка все це забере. Не по мішку, не по кілограму, а повністю машину.
Ринок приносить до 20% доходу в бюджет Великокопанівської громади.
Втім, насправді прибуток від цього бізнесу міг би бути в рази більшим.
Належить ринок родині колишнього народного депутата України - Федора Негоя.
Податківці регулярно вказують власникам ринку на недотримання
податкового законодавства. Зокрема, порушення стосуються
декларування прибутків, використання касових апаратів та неофіційного
працевлаштування з "зарплатами у конвертах".
Через рік ринок планує розширюватись. На орендованій в громаді землі
вже почались будівельні роботи. Тут хочуть зробити гарні торгові місця,
з водовідведенням, аби, приміром, не було таких калюж, як нині.
Планують встановити холодильні камери. Новий ринок - кажуть тут з гордістю -
буде "європейського зразка". Втім, без повної легалізації роботи
як усього ринку, так і кожного окремого підприємця -
справді європейським йому не стати.
Починати цей процес потрібно з селян, які вирощують і продають городину.
Адже з понад двох тисяч фермерських господарств лише сотня оформленні як підприємці.
Втім, у селищній раді проблеми в цьому не бачать.
Немає сенсу ставити  людей в залежність від держави і створювати ФОПи.
Вони сплачують земельний податок і це є їхньою оплатою
за те, що вони користуються землею.
За українським законодавством, діяльність таких фермерів не належить до підприємницької.
Вважається, що вони мають "особисті селянські господарства".
Це коли родина  на власній землі вирощує городину для себе, а надлишок продає.
З одного боку, це справедливо, каже адвокат з земельного права Олександр Поліводський.
Адже гроші, які родина виторгувала на базарі - це не прибуток.
Туди закладені витрати на посів, утримання і збір урожаю.
Втім, з іншого боку  це порушує принцип, що кожен має платити податок.
Особливо коли йдеться про великі господарства, які вирощують продукцію
здебільшого на продаж та наймають робітників.
На переконання адвоката, легалізація відкрила б якраз таким селянам нові можливості.
Цим особам треба теж подивитись, що податок, якщо встановити - це 5%,
а це вже не так і багато, але взамін людина отримує комфорт фінансовий,
безпеку, бо це безготівкова операція і кошти не зручно тримати і пошук нових партнерів.
Фермерка Ірина каже, що реєструвати свій бізнес поки не збирається…
Ми платимо податок за землю і стараюсь не просрочувати.
Прийшов час в серпні - заплатила і забула, до наступного року.
Чи треба реєструватись як ФОП? Ні, у нас не було таких пропозицій...
Хоча перспектива платити податок від прибутку її не тішить.
Каже, що і так не живуть в розкоші. Поїхати на море, що за 100 кілометрів від села,
дозволяють собі раз чи два за сезон.
А за кордоном відпочивали лише в Єгипті.
Сама ж фермерка, як і її наймані працівники,
щодня прокидається о п’ятій ранку, аби почати роботу на городі.